Okay. The 14 moons of
Neptune or a strange bunch.
Most of them are small potato
shaped pieces of ice and rock.
Some so far away from Neptune that they
need to 29 years to circle Neptune once.
Almost all of them are restaurants
trapped by Neptune's gravity.
99.5% of all the mass around
Neptune is concentrated in Tryson.
It's the seventh biggest moon and more
massive than all other known moons in the
solar system.
That house smaller than itself combined.
It's surface area is about as big as
the mainland of Russia and Australia
together.
Also,
Triton is one of only four objects
in the solar system that we know is
geologically active.
Tryson orbits Neptune in
the wrong direction against
the rotation of net unit,
which is unique and how so to system
for an object as big as Triton.
We can conclude from this. The Triton
hasn't always been a moon of Neptune,
but probably was a dwarf planet that
was forced into submission by knap June
when the solar system was
younger and more chaotic.
The most popular theory here is the
Tryson was once part of a double system.
When Neptune migrated to the
outer edges of the solar system,
it's gravity interfered with a double
system and catapulted the other objective
to space.
While Triton was forced into orbis,
this would have disrupted the orbits of
other net tune moons rather violently,
and would most likely have either
pushed them away from Neptune,
all let them collide
or crash into Neptune.
This would explain why Neptune's
moons are so dominated by Triton,
but this will end one day.
Triton is being slowed down by Neptune
and eventually it will either crash into
it all be ground by Neptune's gravity
into a shoe during system similar to
assassins.
So don't buy real estate on Triton.